hey guy sounds like I would welcome to a
video I hate having to figure out intro
for videos I am still excited because
today we have launched the first episode
of my new show hardwired which is not a
0 l and I'm so dang I already said I was
excited so I don't wanna say he said and
I am make anything for you guys to find
all of the episodes and all of our
behind-the-scenes content you can just
go to my youtube channel and I made a
hardwired playlist so you can just go
there watch all of the episodes and some
of our behind-the-scenes stuff and
tomorrow or today or I already did it
depending upon when you're watching this
thursday may sixteen i'm gonna be doing
an ama on reddit you don't know what
that is it's an ask me anything going to
ask me questions and I answer them sort
of like a nice guy j but on reddit I've
been working so hard of the show over
the past couple of actually months we've
had a few shoots at it's so crazy
working on a really big show because
what I'm doing my videos look at my
professional setup here as a camera and
I actually have a little light that is
tied to a tripod with the USB cord and
even the camera that I'm using is also
tied to my tripod because I always lose
the bottom sitting on yoga blocks I
might have the equipment she did stuff
but it's really not too bro this is the
perfect show for me because it's all
about wearable technology which if you
follow my Instagram or you've been
following my vlogs you know that I am
obsessed I mean when I go to the gym I
look like I look like I don't know Gotye
look like a robot or best buy so find is
one day when I was at the gym this girl
comes up to me and she is you probably
get a better workout if you purchase
girl first of all mine drill work out
because what I've got going on here is a
lot of things that you may not be able
to comprehend first off I haven't
happened my iphone but I'm using to
train for a 10k so another app on set
iphone just monitoring my heart rate as
we speak just watch on my arm that's
well it's not there right now usually it
is it's syncing to my heart rate monitor
and also monitoring all of my step you
see this job on up that right there is
not only monitoring my steps but it also
matters all of my food intake and my
sleeping activity or lack of sleeping
activity because I think I say up all
night blank all dude
let me know what you guys think of the
first episode next week there's going to
be another one on Wednesday so stay
tuned for that but right now that in
replying to comments in the first
episode so get over there leave me some
comments and maybe i will reply most
likely or apply since I'm as I'm
speaking to you right now I'm probably
in that thread writing back to all of
you make sure you like and favorite the
first episode because it's an entirely
new channel and it needs some love from
you guys I'll see you soon I love you
the human body creates millions of
points of data every single day most of
which goes unnoticed or even uncollected